hi everyone it's Jerry I am going to hop
into an hourly build Arena
it's been a while
27 minute
event one minute chest I'm going to try
and fishing pole
everybody
for white or black that's my plan of
attack
it's tough to do that with E5
see with the reaction okay
so much for that I had to abort on this
plan
okay
just to put the queen here
fin Keto
expecting C6
okay
uh let's get this in undermining this
point
a little afraid of a skewer
okay I'd like to be able to move this
Pawn I have to defend my Bishop
if E4 I'm not sure what I'm doing on e4
this this
this this now
uh maybe this
oh I forgot about that move I should
have had A4 in first
let's lock it up
let's break this down
I'm on A6
I may take I think I could get out of
the PIN
B5
okay
let's just withdraw
a gunning for that okay
go after D6 Maybe
Queen is on that
get out of Harm's Way
and they don't have any time
take with the Knight say check
it's probably unnecessary but
all right
got the first one in it's a small
showing here 56 not too many in there
okay I have a chance maybe for
the true fishing pole
okay no e4s I want to see E4
okay I could still try it here
uh maybe I should have ruled out an ip5
all right let's get this in
hmm
don't take out the pawn
because this guy is more effective now
it's very simplified
okay I guess we're gonna trade
here gets trapped
hmm I'll take with this open the a file
A3 here fixed Pawn on a dark Square
this might be a requirement C4 yeah
okay no probably Queen side castles no
to watch out for the skewer
on trade improve the king
well these two
yeah I don't think I have anything here
um
hmm
I need to have it open somehow
I want to be able to get at this point
whoa they gave the file
this Pawn is super valuable
yeah now it can't be stopped
I think the best try was just giving
checks
no stalemates
okay might have had a I made one move
sooner
I'm in second
all right these fly by
so far I've been denied no
no no no
fishing poles
no successful fishing poles
not really threatening anything just yet
now I am okay it's defended
just gonna try and undermine this Knight
maybe a sacrifice here whoo
successful fishing pole
got one as the pack leader
okay
let's see
E4
all right well I don't care about the
doubled
the double death Pawns
now it's much closer to eliminating the
defender of H2 threading a mating two
gotta play G3
it's looking like it
and the tank
so even if I don't get the mate this is
shaving off a lot of seconds here G3
what am I doing exactly probably taking
the knight in withdrawing the night
okay
I still don't even want to take he has a
square
oh now it's different
Escape squares gun
doesn't have F1
back-to-back fishing poles
success I might be getting Nona fried
here
no
resignation
okay
50 percent
the fishing poles
okay
82 in here now
all right this is the number three guy
it's tough to do the fishing pole with
the against the fee and Keto
but
[Music]
um
okay let's get fiend cut out first
yeah I was looking at maybe playing F3
and G4
let's try this
um
I don't want a castle queenside
I'm gonna Castle nowhere
no side
no sides gasoline
okay
is this too crazy
around the queen
okay
um
okay I'm on I have this covered actually
the open G file
trying to undermine that
scary
fight over this F3 Square
okay I almost don't even want to take it
I want to get this in maybe
okay gotta run
I have a sneaky move I think this one
check checkmate if there's capture
Rook has to move
oh
I didn't see the move
oh that's a fancy way to give me
okay
somehow managing to cause trouble
some crazy King side attacks
all right
Dumbledore is in second played
no we haven't played
okie dokie
computer's not going the fastest
a little slow here
peace movements
I want to keep the queen on the diagonal
take with the pawn
still stay trained on H2
okay I have to I have to respect this
move so
to pull the plug in
this H5 idea should I take with the
bishop I'm running into Knight takes
Pawn
so I have to just be okay
with what
let's go here
careful if I played here there's Rook
takes E6
I'm gonna go here because I want to
Queen trade at this point
Queen's way too active
oh okay
my Queen's in a good position now if she
comes back here I could go for trades
King's on the same color Square as my
unopposed Bishop so oh I missed that
okay
do something on the diagonal
I don't know if I really even want to
take that
maybe hint at it
Big Time Edge
I want to keep this bishop
hmm pins
you could take
whoops
okay
not the slickest conversion there very
messy
15 minutes to go got a lot of games in
six games
okay oh this was the one of the
successful fishing pole games
don't for it again
I could back off
I'm gonna try something different now
I'll still go there okay maybe not now
okay
abort
no fishing
okay I do not mind the doubled Pawns
I want my knight here
I think I'm gonna sit if here I don't
want to give up this big Square so
um
not sure entirely what this move is
doing
Maybe
I could do this if this guy gets going
take and then and then here a really
strong night now
it has turned technical
maybe a little too yeah
oh okay
there
this was not the
greatest way to play this
will take
um oh I could track this Pawn down
yeah oh they're all falling
Pac-Man mode I'm hitting everything
let's keep going after them
let's hang on to that guy
oh
to watch out
whoo
not good not good got the W but
slow going
okay
it's tough to break that down
um
no it's too much
I wanted to take that back and go with
the pawn instead
break down the light squares
I want to get at this point
I should have oh I had that move already
Queen takes Pawn
oh it's mate next
whoo
didn't realize that
this clean to clean Bishop too
it's been working out
all right
uh all right
let's go for this
yeah maybe should have stopped this
advance
keep the file
I was just ready to play here oh
it would have been bad
not a fan of this structure okay wait
in a dark Square Bishop Exchange
and get a skewer if it takes
I think I get a skewer no matter what oh
they have this move
yeah even after a queen exchange this
okay
I didn't not sure entirely what's going
on with that
maybe here first
yeah they're trying to get in A5
sake with the pawn
here here
my time is not good
let me go with the pawn
whoa
totally missed that move oh I must
blundered there
too
oh it's still me
oh I only had .02 seconds there too oh
it was so sloppy
okay
I've been extinguished
oh they thought I was gonna move my
knight there it's a free night
okay those are two quick points
119 in here now
okay
what's that move about
I had that one too
let's go with the Jeep on
got some attack on
the open H file
something here
take their
Queen's gonna be challenged right away
my time
oh got the fork
might take this night
I had a check
still have a check oh I have to give up
the night now
yeah it's over
no stalemates
okay
all right seven in change
Brian
no free night this time
sniffing up
everybody's sniffing out the fishing
pole
hmm oh I was supposed to move the pond
first
order
oh
oh I don't have
my queen is in the way
whoops
close still close
let's go here this and then here
if this I have mate
a knight here
will be good
maybe they block with the pawn
be mate
okay
I don't even know what I'm doing
um
I don't know what that move is it either
trying to do something
I'm asking for a discovery
oh man 1.8
it's just a rat race there's under five
minutes holy cow this really flies by
okay now going back here you get trapped
I exchanged Knights and then C5
there's no good Retreat square if the
Knight is captured
um
not sure what that's doing
okay here and in here
stop B5
oh
I get forked if I take the pawn
defend like this
don't know how to make progress really
um yeah I don't know what am I supposed
to do
lost so much time there
clean trade
oh wait that's hanging
getting a piece oh I think the bishop
had to go there
pigs
oh
I got Knight here everything's going to
be hitting that soon
hang on
got me very soon
one and two okay
one more game should count
let's see and have the chat open
I wonder if the word got out
just now we're just trying to fishing
pole everybody watch out
oh man
I'll have a
a quick peek after the tournament's over
got a few in there
so pause at least it's good news
oh yeah let's just take that guy
excellent position golden Square for a
night a bishop
I'll go just one
just to prevent any possible sacrifices
oh
get some development in Bishop here
there's a knight B5 move
Rook is a little stuck
I'll go Queen side castles now
here I think I'll take maybe rookie Rook
here was better
I got this covered well enough
um
let's go here here
try to get it H2 still
got this
this
get something it's made if they take the
pawn oh
all right
that should be the last one that counts
for the event
under a minute
possible to get a quick win in
okay
he's having a little fun here with this
rare local record
oh
I could get away with taking that
oh we're getting we're getting this dark
Square Bishop again
it's almost me
The Rook in the corner
not happening
it's almost a bad Mouse slip
be completely winning
then scary going on on these squares
um
it's actually a bit irritating
okay could take with check
not the smoothest conversion
I want my king on C4
I should have played there sooner
it's a good thing that's not hitting a
check
I didn't check to see if that was
hitting with check
okay that one did not count
almost some piece in the corner pocket
for a a quick checkmate
okay nobody's talking about fishing
poles they're not onto me
all right
a good games all
fun to get in some bullet every now and
then
and it has been a while 150 in there
46 30 29 top three
there's the top ten who's the top 50.
three four five
okay
all right that's gonna do it feel free
as usual to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below
I hope you enjoyed it
probably didn't take a thing away from
it though all right that's all for now
take care bye